hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
i've had a few requests in the past to
cover uh less traditional approaches to
building dax digital to analog
converters
and i recently reviewed a product of
that type
it's from a company called audio gd in
china
the specific model that i tested is
called the master 7 singularity
you can see the title of over here
pretty fancy sounding name
um
i've tested a number of products from
this company before when i first started
measuring electronic equipment and the
performance was quite poor and
the other thing was weird is that the
company shows measurements on their site
and my measurements never match theirs
and uh you know it turns out that just
their measurements are just obscure or
even though their outputs are body
precision there are no scales on them or
test conditions and at any rate that it
never seemed like what they were showing
was was accurate
um and a lot of people bought their
copenhagen because they saw the
measurements and assumed that it you
know products were that good
fast forward to three years later people
wondering if
the products had improved
and the member was kind enough to loan
me a much more recent product this one
came out in 2018.
it's discontinued again they seem to
have a revolving door as far as dags and
version numbers but it's a lot more
recent than than the copen that i tested
in the past
and the owner bought this around i think
said
in spring of
2018 so not that old
uh on this thing
um it's one of the heaviest and largest
decks i've tested it's a massive box and
it's quite deep i've already shipped it
back to the owner otherwise i will show
you but in this picture the perspective
doesn't show it but it is very very deep
and very very wide and very heavy
um i think it's like i don't know
20 kilograms or you know 40 50 pounds or
something like that
and if you go look at the picture down
here that i have of it you'll see why
it's got these three giant transformers
in the front together with this large
chassis
and
that makes it quite heavy
when you look inside of it oh by the way
the price is pretty high this is a 2500
uh dax so compared to a desktop deck so
we measure for a few hundred dollars
it's about 10 times the price and you do
get 10 times the weight and maybe a
whole lot more than ten times the
components
um the heart of this dac is is this uh
ti pcm 1704 uh
dac chips and they actually use four of
them in each channel you can see a row
of them over here and a row of them over
here
when you combine dax you can improve
their signal noise ratio because the
output scales linearly but the noise
doesn't combine linearly so you gain
signal noise ratio so quite a attempt in
here to to try to do this this this uh
dac chip has been discontinued
uh so they probably bought all they
could and then when they couldn't buy
anymore to stop building it uh i don't
know if they still have stock and use it
in other products
and uh there's a quite a bit of fat out
there as far as people wanting these
more older dac chips even though the
newer ones easily outperform them and
there's this mystique around them and
the moment the manufacturer says they're
using these stacks in non-oversampling
which is one of the modes this this
supports
you know many people have warm fuzzies
about this and uh
anyway that's why this this company's
chosen to to go this route
but typical of their products they also
use a ton of discovery components you
can't see them in the picture because
these are all little transistors instead
of using a single ic you know op amp
that
handles amplification and buffering
they've built their own circuit which
can perform well if done right um and
we'll see later on whether this one does
or not
and so this is one channel dac on the
right this is the other channel on the
back and right and then in the middle is
all the digital logic and control
there's a fpga chip over here alturate i
think
and
that's basically programmable logic you
can use specialized tools where you can
design a you know complicated logic
circuit and then you embed it and
download it into this chip and
it morphs into what that circuit is so
it is able to encapsulate thousands and
tens of thousands of you know discrete
parts and they're large ones that can
hold you know millions of such
components i don't think this one's that
big
but anyway they they use this thing um
to for clocking functions you have
multiple inputs all of different formats
and you gotta
get everything in a way that these you
know these standalone dac chips can
accept so that's all in here um
what makes it large and complicated also
is that they have these three
transformers then they have this very
elaborate uh three power supplies over
here also one for you know one for left
channel one for right channel one for
this digital section so as far as you
know paper goes and paper design goes
this seems like very very over overdone
and you know on a good side you know if
you're going to throw kitchen sink at
the design as long as you do it right
should incrementally improve things and
certainly shouldn't hurt things
and anyone looking at the picture of
this thing will say wow this is a lot
more impressive than getting a desktop
dac that i test that you know if you
take the top off it's very you know
disappointing there's only a few ics you
know hooked up together and the whole
board maybe the you know fraction of the
size of this
so
ostensibly it feels good even feels good
to me as an engineer i look at this
they're like wow a lot of design work
went into
one disappointing thing is that they
always provide the usb
as a usb input as an add-on card i could
understand 10 or 15 years ago
doing that but it's sitting over here
bolted down sideways in here
and the connector in the back and and
you have to pay extra for that and i
don't know if that's still the case but
a lot of times
you paid another hundred fifty two
hundred dollars just to have usb and usb
is the most common input to these decks
today so you shouldn't be an
afterthought should be a standard part
uh i got a kick out of if you go through
a manual there's no manual it's just a
little one page on their website that's
the manual
and it starts right away with this red
note over here that they actually have
burned in this device for 300 hours
before they shipped it to you credit to
them instead of saying you have to
listen to it for 300 hours but they go
back and say other people have said you
got to burn it for another 150 hours
and maybe even more and up to a thousand
hours may be beneficial
i don't know about you but i'll be old
and dead
waiting for a thousand hours just to use
this uh 2500 attack
uh but anyway they say another seven
hundred dollars so per name maybe use so
thankfully this came from an owner who's
used it for three four years so maybe it
is already at a thousand hours i don't
know there's no hour meter on it if they
want to insist on these things then they
better have an hour meter just like
uh you know a lot of uh
generators and what have you have it uh
so uh you know suggestion for them in
the future put an hour meter so you know
if it's been burning
when i started to measure this stack i
usually you know start with this
dashboard those of you who have seen my
reviews
you know remember this but as i ran this
every two to three seconds or it seemed
to be all the numbers would randomize
and
the generator would have the analyzer
would have to relock to the signal and i
noticed that this frequency measurement
which right now says one kilo is right
on the money would jump down to a 0.999
a number and then immediately switch
back to this one kilohertz and i was
like whoa what the heck is going on
there let's see if i can trace that so i
run the same one kilohertz tone but this
time i asked the analyzer as time went
by to just plot this the frequency
counter and so it plots it at one
kilohertz right on the money boom boom
boom is going and all of a sudden at 1.5
seconds
we get a sudden drop in in clock to this
precise number of 0.9930
kilohertz and then it goes back up to
one kilohertz and continues and then it
glitches down then it goes and glitches
down and discontinues forever
this is a fatal design error uh
basically they're
they're trying to synchronize on some
internal dac clock to another device
that's generating data so in this case
let's say you uh the clock on a dac and
the clock on a usb module and
you can get into situations where
they lose lock or you know a buffer
overruns or under runs that means that
they're not able to regulate the speed
of the two interfaces together so that
they stay in sync and right there a
glitch happens now glitch is very short
i don't know how audible it is but it's
certainly very measurable and it's just
a
it's just a sin i mean
the whole purpose of having that fpga
and elaborate clocking and everything
that it does is to not have this
and the fact that it winds up with a
clear signaling error and design error
is just
boggles my mind especially in something
that's high-end
i don't know how they don't see
something as simple like as this this is
a verification that you do in your
design and
it's extremely rare to find this and
here it is happening
and
the what i had to do then to capture
this the graph is that normally i
average
uh three scans of this so that you don't
see all this noisiness but i have to
turn off the averaging in this case
because if i waited to average all of a
sudden the clock would change and this
whole display would get screwed up so
don't mind the noisiness in here that's
just the measurement artifact um but
basically if you just look at it you see
also very high distortion spikes on one
channel i don't know if you can see the
blue in here it's much worse than the
other one so the second harmonic is much
worse and you can see that reflected in
this cyanate rating one is 89 db that
one's 81 db so 8 db difference within
the two channels so that's a lot of
mismatch to have you know 102 db
difference i see that in many decks but
8 db means just a tremendous lack of
precision in design of that circuit and
you know when you go discreet you wind
up losing that kind of precision and you
better have feedback or other mechanisms
to compensate for that or some kind of
uh you know hand selecting components
but clearly that wasn't done
um the dac produces a
5.7 volts instead of a nominal four
volts which is fine
and i loaded the input to it there's no
volume control by the way that this
giant that's big it should have remote
control on the volume doesn't have it so
i dialed in the input in digital domain
2 db to get it close to 4 volts on this
thing
and so running with this number yes
versus distortion and noise combined at
one kilohertz i averaged the two
channels when they're different and
the rating winds up way into the poor
category um you know i don't tell you to
try to focus on exact numbers but i've
got broadly four
buckets that that that can fall into us
for sum of noise and distortion
and
you know when anything's in the red just
means
it's just there was no attention to
detail and it's like going to a
restaurant and and you literally can see
your plates are dirty and food stuck to
them from previous dish that they serve
to somebody else uh that's what this red
category is maybe you won't get sick and
in this case maybe you won't hear the
artifacts but i sure as heck don't want
to spend any money for a deck that lands
in here um if you want to see it better
uh it still doesn't show that well in
the review but uh you can click on this
thing and in the uh on the website and
see it clearly and you can see all of
his neighbors in here and
uh it's not in you know a good company
um there is a apple dongle here there's
about a hundred signet and this one's at
81 83 or whatever the averages are
um interestingly enough
when i change the digital input from usb
to coax or toslink
the results are very different first
that clocking issue disappears
so that means it's not an
instrumentation problem with me or
device being broken per se it's just
that that interface with that external
usb input is done poorly so when you use
coax for example you can see that you
know the frequency is still stable at
one kilohertz but then we get new
problems
look at all this junk in here around our
main tone our main tone is this one
spike by the way everything else is
unwanted none of this should be there an
ideal device would have this one spike
and this noise floor would be off the
charts
um you know even the best device won't
have a noise floor that falls off the
chart it'll be down here but they
wouldn't have all this garbage in here
we have a whole bunch of stuff there's a
bunch of things from multiples of 100 i
don't know if that's power supply noise
120 hertz uh and multiples it could be
oars 100 hertz
um but regardless there's also some
crazy amount of sperry tones in here
that just make give this thing what i
call a skirt and it should none of that
should be there should be a clean pure
spike in here and then we have harmonics
in here the
second and third harmonic and then
fourth and fifth and sixth and seven and
goes on uh on this thing um
it doesn't impact the cyanide score that
much it changes a hair because the
distortion is so loud that it dominates
this score
but this other junk is also there
and that was with coax input with uh
tussling input it changes again i mean
it's still dirty
but it changes again so what this says
is that the activity inside the device
depending on what input you light up
there's
different profile of noise and garbage
bleeding onto the dax channels that's
the first thing you want to do when you
design what is called a mixed signal
device we have digital circuits in the
dac and we have analog circuits and
they're very very sensitive and you want
to isolate those two things and they
seem to have done it on per you know on
paper with that middle
card being all digital and the two sides
being the analog thing but physical
separation is only part of your problem
there are connections that go from
digital to analog section and they're
bleeding noise into there and something
that you can't see in here and sorry
this text is obscure
but it says that the noise floor was
moving when i was watching this display
in real time i would actually see the
noise flow rising and going up and down
so even getting modulated up and down on
this thing so some other low frequency
changes in operation of the device was
bleeding into the deck both channels of
the deck one channel i think was worse
the one in red
and it was just climbing up and down
swinging up and down on its own
so
all of this basically again going back
to that dish analogy it just means
you're finding all kinds of you know
they bring you bread in the restaurant
and the bread is stale and and mildew in
your glass of water comes in and the
glass is dirty it's like everywhere you
look on this
you know graph just shows you that
just noise and and poor attention to
proper execution sure you want to use
those you know older dac's go ahead and
do them but please produce clean nice
best performance those dag chips can
produce don't just bleed a whole bunch
of noise and stuff in there where your
job as an implementer is to not screw up
the performance of that detection
if we take its just signal noise ratio
all these noise problems come back to
haunted here too
um signal noise ratio is 17 bits so you
might say well it's a little bit better
than cd at 16 bits but yeah you're
paying 2500 for something that
barely can reproduce the noise floor of
a 40 year old cd standard
state of the art products go to 22 bits
and this number would be 125 126. so
what this says also is that if you play
at 100 db
peaks uh your noise floor would be
audible at your uh you know from your
speaker uh because of the 100 db down is
where this thing generates noise and
that's above threshold of hearing so
even if you want to make an argument oh
maybe i won't hear those well if you
turn it loud enough uh you will hear a
noise floor and by the way the noise is
additives if it's just your dac and if
you hook it up to an amplifier headphone
amp or power up and everything all those
noise floors keep cascading and adding
up so your source you want it to be very
clean and very transparent and clearly
this is not transparent and this is all
at the feet of the designer as far as
implementing things
so far i've only showed you the
measurements for the balance out with
the xlr output it also has a set of rca
outputs first are measured with balance
this is intermodulation test so it has a
60 hertz tone and a seven killer stone
in a four to one ratio so this test into
test simultaneously measures the
performance of the dac in both low
frequency and high frequency and then
you see it as a combined single imd
number that is then plotted depending on
the input level so the input levels
start very low and gradually go all the
way up to the max
and
i have two references for you in blue is
a state of the art
state of york a very good dac that came
out
two years ago topping the x3 pro
and that's a 200 or 250 dollar deck and
headphone combo it's down here and then
i have one in orange
which is a
razer the phone company uh headphone
dongle which is a nine dollar little
dongle you connect and lets you listen
to your headphones on your phone
and
the performance of of
this audio gde master 7
is the same as that dongle as you can
see in one channel it barely is better
than the other one with balanced output
so as it is it's quite embarrassing that
a 9 dongle has less noise and distortion
or similar noise and distortion than
that but amazing thing happens the
moment you hook up an rca output look at
what happens to distortion and noise it
shoots way the heck up
around -30 db and then it finishes
around -40 i mean that's just 40 db
worse than balanced output
i mean it just must be a hack of how
they implemented unbalanced output
without a proper merging circuit
converting differential to
non-differential it's just not excusable
i mean
any device that i've tested recently or
even budget desktop products when they
have both connectors they do a half
decent job of at least getting these two
to be very close usually two or three db
difference not 40 db difference in
performance so the rca output in this
thing is just truly junk and hard uh
suggest if you have this device uh the
stack you just use balanced output xlr
app
on this thing
um so i went ahead and plotted the
spectrum just to see what it looks like
so this is our dashboard again um
now two volts unbalances half the output
and look at this now we have almost
point three percent distortion so forget
about having lots of zeros in here we
can't even get one zero squeeze in here
and look at the second harmonic it
shoots way the heck up here and so do
the other harmonics in here so you get
this whole spray of harmonics and we
still have all of our noise in here
so very very embarrassing just totally
unacceptable performance
um i was surprised actually in jitter
tests for usb was actually quite good so
that amanero
module they use must have a good
clocking circuit in there that actually
produces pretty low noise and distortion
relatively speaking again their desktop
dax are much better than this but for
this device in blue is the usb screen
but i searched the toslink and coax also
the noise floor jumps these two are
tossling and coax
and as you can see they have different
spurious patterns they don't match each
other so
uh on this thing so it just
another black eye for the stack you know
an ideal dac wouldn't care what digital
input you use right bits of bits digital
is digital well bits are not bits for
this stack depending on which input you
use different parts of the circuit light
up and they create different level of
noise and interference and so
you're kind of stuck if you use usb you
have that clocking error that's going to
cost glitches every one and a half
seconds if you use coax and and toslink
inputs then you have high noise floors
and much more jitter
so
really poor
um it did better in this multi-tone test
multi-tone test has 32 tones
simultaneously put in the one one
waveform and the level though is lower
even though it says zero in here is
lower than the one killer's totem had in
there so it doesn't generate as much
distortion so it allows the device to
perform better now
as far as distortion-free ranges 15 to
17 killers and you can see this rise in
distortions the higher the frequency the
worse it gets and that's
typical though again this is
unacceptable level for anything that's
half decent
as far as dex is concerned
since the output is more than four volts
i often run a sweep and show you whether
there are more optimal positions than
the one that i measured i measured at
4.3 volts so i went ahead and sweep the
input level and step it up gradually and
then we measure the output level and
show it over here and then we also show
the sign add which is thd plus and noise
and usually the graph sort of climbs
like this and then some devices saturate
and then it comes down
this one is sort of go does that a
little bit but then all sudden
performance drops halfway in the middle
like
it doesn't like to output 1.5 volt
output then it gets better again
clearly this is just designer i've never
seen anything like this this is makes no
sense it should be noise at the bottom
and that dominates and causes the curve
to go up and then it saturates at some
point and comes down so we see the
saturation coming down an ideal output
is around four volts so what i measured
is more or less you know what it best
they can do but the worse it can do is
actually around 1.5 volts so
to the extent that the input digital
samples get lower in amplitude all
sudden it has higher distortion and
noise than if there are maximum or at
lower levels so
you have to shake your head i don't know
what else you do
and that shaking of the head
continues in that i have this linearity
test ideal of linearity would be that
it does and we get a flat line in here
this is the smallest signal we could
feed the dac and this is the loudest
signal we could feed the dac it does
okay here but as they get lower it it
has a simple error amount of error it
steps down and stays there and sort of
gradually gets worse then it steps down
again and then it picks up some noise
this kind of wiggliness
it's not great but we're going to get
that at these very low levels but this
kind of steppiness just means precision
er error in uh
output stage and and the buffer stage
that it has post attack
it basically has an offset and a few
micro volts and
and causes this error to show up whereas
half a db of error in amplitude by the
time you get down to -95 db so
signal designer
um
typical of these dacs they go book for
what is fashionable and it's fashionable
these days to basically have no
filtering uh nyquist theorem says a
digital sales
dac a digital system of analog to
digital and digital to analog conversion
can be perfectly accurate as long as you
chop off all the high frequencies above
half the sample rate when you digitize
it and then you do the same again when
you convert a digital back to analog
so whoever created your music probably
has done that probably filtered
everything and but at playback time the
stack chooses to not do the reverse it
instead has this very slow filter where
it just
you know this is where the line i've
drawn is where it should go down to
nothing so it should be like this flat
and then it should go down
and now that's an ideal dag not an ideal
deck sort of gold a bit past it but this
thing does not even want to attenuate
even when you go way past it so it's
basically allowing ultrasonic junk and
noise to come out of the dac
that with a high bandwidth amplifier
it'll also get amplified and it'll get
sent to a twitter
most speakers and tweeters don't go that
high so as a practical matter it
probably doesn't do much um but there's
just no reason for it it's all folklore
that this kind of deck yeah this kind of
filter does better
there's a jumper in there you can put
change things but i could not understand
their english and i'm very good at
reading you know poor english that's
translated from chinese or japanese but
i could not make sense out of what they
were saying the jumpers did so i did not
attempt to change it the owner had not
changed it and this is exactly how the
box ships so to the extent people don't
muck with it this is the filter response
now final test iran gets impacted by
that and this is our you know when i
show you the dashboard
the dashboard tested one kilohertz one
frequency only
now a well-designed box will not care
about what frequency you throw at it
but not all devices are well designed
and even well-designed ones may have
more distortion at high frequencies or
low frequencies or anywhere else so to
detect that i run a sweep now i tell the
analyzer look change the frequency from
20 hertz to 20 kilos the audible band
and at every step pause
measure thc plus n which is uh you know
our cyanide basically and it's expressed
as a percentage on left and expressed as
a db on the right and uh go ahead and
plot that so if i just run that test
actually let me step back every at every
point we want to measure the harmonic
distortion that means multiples of our
test tone so we have 20 kilohertz the
second harmonic would be 40 kilohertz uh
third harmonic would be 60 kilos and on
so for this test to produce
correct result the bandwidth needs to be
a lot higher than 20 kilohertz to be
able to capture all of that in the
analyzer and see the harmonic distortion
so to do that i have a bandwidth of 90
kilohertz in here so i can go four times
the 20 kilohertz in here and catch up up
to fourth harmonic the dashboard only
runs at 22 kilos so the dashboard is
good enough for one kilo or stone but
doesn't include all this noise above the
audible band this one does so when we do
that when i run this test at 20 hertz
the distortion is already hugely high
this dash line is a 99 board that was a
bargain a few years ago and and and
today that's
average performance and it's down here
and look at how much worse the
distortion is in in this audio gd and
then as the frequencies go up it gets
worse and worse and worse it actually
goes off the chart it'll actually keep
climbing going crazy land and up here is
already at one percent and it'll keep
going
and this gets caused because of this
filter this filter is not getting rid of
the extra
mirrors that are concerned that are
generated of our tone
and they get added in as and get
expressed as noise and distortion and so
they inflate this number
um to remove the effect of this slow
filter i can also run the same test at
192 kilo sampling i won't talk about why
that's the case but when i write it at
192 it basically assumes we now have a
perfect filter even when i do that look
at the response first the two channels
don't match one is a lot more distorted
than the other one and but look at how
much worse the distortion is we're now
to a sign out of only 65.
remember i showed you about 80 to 90 db
at one kilohertz but at 20 kilohertz
distortion has shot way up uh by almost
20 db worst distortion and
uh we're now at 0.05 percent distortion
so very very poor and again the two
channels don't match and way worse than
even you know bargain tax that you can
buy today
by the way this is one reason why you
want extremely good sign ad scores at
one killers in a dashboard because if
the engineers done a phenomenal job in
here at one kilohertz then chances are
even if there is a rise it won't climb
this high and you can see that indeed in
this sparring deck in here at one
kilohertz is down here a sign out of
about a 105. so yes it also climbs up
but it climbs from such a good bait you
know floor that it only climbs up to
minus 85 so it's still extremely good
this one starts at such a poor sign out
of you know 80 db here at one kilohertz
and then it goes up similar amount but
now it's in really really poor uh
category of dac performance
so
where are we uh same work place we were
a company has shown another measurement
on their website that you can't make
heads and tails but it's an audio
precision measurement so clearly the
company
cares or promotes measurements otherwise
why why would they stick a audio
precision output plot in there and but
it definitely is not of this device
maybe a prototype maybe something else
maybe made up i don't know what i do
know is that
nothing in there i can generate and by
the way what they have is not great
either but
you know what i'm measuring is far worse
than that
um
so what do we have in here we have a
case of
designer either personally believing or
chasing audiophile hype and myths that
you want to use these older chips that
the the companies who designed them are
considering them obsolete and
discontinued but somehow audiophiles
know more than the chip company and they
think they sound better and perform
better fine go ahead and execute and
build a dac that is as good as that chip
can deliver
and here they got four of them together
that means should be a lot better should
have much better dynamic range
no what's been put around those dag
chips is just horrific and the design is
simply not verified all you got to do
when you design a product like this make
a suite of measurements like this they
have an audio precision analyzer run
these measurements and look at these
things i mean there's no way any of this
is planned you can't tell me that a
designer thought all this grunginess
that they added to the noise floor it's
goodness for you uh every audiophile
gushes about you know black backgrounds
and deeper into the noise floor while
this thing is a noise factory it's also
a distortion factory but not any kind of
tube distortion or anything you can say
it's euphonic uh most people will not
the most i'll guarantee audiophiles
can't hear these distortions because if
they did
they wouldn't buy this product or return
it right away
so it's not good distortion either it's
just
bad design and
they get away with it because of the
aura they have and the branding and
reputation and the fact that
you know as audiophiles are as people
we're very forgiving of non-linearity
and distortions like this so we get to
not hear it and instead we let ourselves
get biased by the reputation and and the
size and the weight of the box and what
somebody says on the internet and go and
write them a twenty five hundred dollar
check when you could buy a hundred
dollar deck that runs circles around it
and uh
maybe you won't hear the improvement but
you sure as heck your bank account would
be much richer because you have 2 400
you can put towards music or do
something else for your hobby so
absolutely please please avoid buying
any product that i haven't measured i
don't want to say everything they build
is bad because i haven't tested
everything they built i can tell you
that everything i've tested all follows
in the same path of
them following myths and building
products with no feedback and all these
things that you know audiophiles think
is better but the proof of the pudding
is that when you measure it
you can see there's no betterness in
there you can see carelessness in design
and by the way this company is
impossible to deal with per se in that
you want to buy this stack you have to
paypal the money in advance to the
company and then they go ahead and send
you a product now i haven't seen anybody
get ripped off that way but should they
take your money and then close the doors
next door or next day how are you going
to get your money back
and it just doesn't make sense you know
if you're going to sell thousand dollar
multi thousand dollar products pay
somebody five bucks to set up an
e-commerce site for you
and have them forbid if you have to get
warranty service on this um if i have a
200 200 dac that goes bad
i don't want to send it to china and
i'll go get another one uh 2500
you're gonna want it repaired and to
pack and ship a 40-pound package to go
back to china and have it come back to
you in one piece and how long it takes
gosh you could have
really really really good reason to go
buy this deck and i i can't give you any
reason to buy this tax so
anyway i don't want to keep ranting on
this uh hopefully you found it useful
and cover and get out of the type of
digital to analog converter
okay
see you in a future video bye-bye